então um dia desses eu tava acordei de
manhã e falei vou no supermercado também
não vou na padaria comprar um frango
assado
naquele dia que você acorda está
querendo conversar com ninguém acorda se
está bem embolado isso ocorrer vou lá
comprar mas se deus quiser ninguém vai
aparecer vai conversar comigo então
cheguei lá na padaria e lá esperando o
frango assado e aí eu vi uma senhora
caminhando na minha direção eu falei meu
deus meu deus ela vai falar comigo ela
vai falar comigo fechei o olho e
coloquei todos os santos que eu conheço
não são muitos
ele não fala não fala fala fala fala
fala fala senhor o calor né
eu falei é calor ela eu acho um absurdo
eu falei o que você acha um absurdo
absurdo que é um calor danado é que o
fórum se imagina lá dentro o cara que
está preparando um frango assado está
passando esse calor absurdo absurdo um
calor colossal o cara é verdade mas a
senhora veio aqui fazer o que a ela eu
vim comprar frango assado
aí a senhora me quebra
aí a senhora complica para o meu lado no
total assim eu já vim falar comigo vai
comprar um frango
aí fiquei pensando em bater um gatilho
na cabeça a gente realmente curtir meter
a boca no trambone é botar a boca no
trombone a nossa especialidade eu digo
que o nosso esporte nacional é reclamar
depois dos 7 a 1 da alemanha cara acabou
futebol negócio é reclamar um grande
amigo meu que também falou na plataforma
até 10 ele diz que existem três tipos de
pessoas gabriel gomez ele ele disse
existem os que reclamam os que fazem e
os que sustentam o apóiam aqueles que
fazem e eu sempre sinto que a gente tem
muita gente reclamando pouca gente
fazendo e pouca gente apoiando a gente
gosta muito de reclamar
a gente gosta muito reclamado vazio é da
ausência a gente aponta o dedo a gente
julga a gente aponta o dedo à
ninguém faz isso quem faz aquilo e aí eu
quero lembrar a vocês que existe um
vazio bom existem vários tipos de vazio
que são maravilhosos
por exemplo sua sogra quando ela não vai
ter churrasco que você fez
maravilhoso vazio é é o teu chefe que
decidiu não ir trabalhar sexta feira
lindo lindo vazio e o vazio do governo
o vazio do governo também pode ser algo
muito bom também pode ser algo muito bom
então eu queria falar no vazio do
governo nesse lugar zinho aí é uma
escola muito especial na minha cidade
niterói
já o colégio estadual alcina que seu
sobrenome do colégio mas é o sina e lá
no alcina o vazio se faz muito presente
ela foi uma escola construída 65 anos
atrás para ser uma escola temporária e
aí ela tá aí temporária até hoje uma
temporalidade muito especial 65 anos
então assim toda a escola é construída
sentem muitas filiações aparentes é tudo
bem temporário lá e essa essa coisa do
da escola temporada acabou tomando conta
dos corpos que estão dentro daquela
escola né
as pessoas esperam as pessoas dentro
daquela escola esperam e continuam
esperando esperaram por esses 65 anos
então quando a gente pisou pela primeira
vez nessa escola a reação foi vocês são
do governo
vocês são a secretaria vocês vão trazer
o governador aqui eu falei 'não e tomara
que ele não venha nunca a torcida que
não vê no que eles não saibam que essa
escola existe né
eles esperaram ele continuou esperando
então assim a maneira como a gente lida
com o vazio definir muito o tipo de
democracia que a gente tem de definir
muito a apropriação do espaço físico né
e definir também quem é que nós queremos
ser
não quero falar um pouco sobre isso a
gente esquece um pouco que o povo não
vir
na verdade é deixar de vir a ser a gente
tem a percepção de que o futuro está em
aberto o futuro a deus pertence
eu tenho uma notícia
e é pra vocês até mesmo tempo vai acabar
o tempo vai consumir o tempo essa é uma
lei uma lei muito pouco famosa mas que
tem que ser famosa é a lei da entropia
uma lei da termodinâmica
tudo será com isso tudo será consumido
tudo se consome inclusive o nosso futuro
então a gente precisa parar de olhar pro
porra vídeo e fazer pelo agora né e aí
esse incômodo que aconteceu lá na escola
naquela escola que eu mostrei me fez
olhar para o futuro e fala assim o ok
mas é preciso fazer agora é olhar para o
presente e aí começando a olhar o
presente olhando para todas essas crises
que a gente vive
eu me fiz essa pergunta o que é mais
escasso hoje 6 acham valendo
eu respondi antes de vocês eu acho que é
tudo tá são todas as anteriores mas eu
marquei duas em especial educação e
consciência que pensando que é mais
escasso educação o consciência ou as
duas
eu acho que a gente tem mais acesso à
educação do que nunca tivemos que
educação é algo super contestável é o
que vai ser falado mais tarde hoje as
consciências essa consciência é algo
mais sério e mais complicado
então no meu ponto de vista a gente está
vivendo uma grande crise uma grande
crise que a gente dá não identificou
muito bem é uma crise de cidadania
cidadania a gente fica pessoas que
cidadania é essa que você tá falando
gostava
aí eu fui pesquisar eu li os conceitos a
dani cheguei em hannah arendt na área
quando fala dos espaços públicos
ela fala de dois tipos de relação o
espaço de aparência eo mundo
compartilhado
vocês já ouviram falar nisso a rã é fera
nela pimpona e como vocês estão vendo na
imagem ela é sensacional
ela precisa chegar a mais pessoas então
esse conceito de espaço de aparência é
aquilo que a gente pode entender como a
esfera em que a gente dialoga sobre a
pólis a esfera em que a gente dialoga
o que nós precisamos fazer para que a
nossa vida seja melhor e aí olhando para
o dia a dia
olhando para a realidade eu me pergunto
que o diálogo
eu tenho uma grande impressão de que a
gente está passando por um processo de
mortes a pisar são da comunicação é o
festival é a surra de monólogo você está
lá alguém escreveu e que a pouco alguém
escreve de volta você fala assim olha
cara vi um filme fantástico ontem ele é
mesmo um cara baixinho é maravilhoso
ninguém se escuta né a gente troca
monólogo e isso não pode saber imagino
na câmara vereador de vereadores e eu
sei que não pode falar de política
não vamos falar sobre isso vamos falar
sobre espaço um espaço de diálogo
o espaço de diálogo desapareceu é uma
ferramenta negligenciada na educação nas
ruas nas redes sociais é monólogo
então essa é a minha visão e aí eu fico
pensando na outra esfera pública
a chegada do mundo compartilhado e aí eu
lembro de ari zinho a empresa está
presente em tudo né
é fantástico é um monstro ele fala da
nossa conjugalidade né de sermos humanos
quando somos conjugais quando
compartilhamos somos humanos iii tarro
também é essa área também não tá legal
essa área da conjugalidade também não
está funcionando
né agente delega muitas das coisas que a
gente pode fazer junto a gente prefere o
sistema de representação que está nos
distanciando do fazer e que está nos
distanciando de nós mesmos como seres
humanos
eu não sei quem falou não sei onde
qualquer coisa do tipo
o ser humano é só uma frase que veio do
meu sócio só se lembra dessa frase
álvaro lembrança fazê-lo assim o ser
humano é o único ser que nas humano e
passou o resto da vida toda tentando ser
humano
ele nasce humano depois e tenta virar
humano de novo disse ele na sua mãe
depois deixou de ser humano e agora fica
tentando seu ano novo
estranho eu entendo que a nossa
humanidade reside no que no que temos de
conjugar onu que dividimos certo e
sempre apresentava beleza onde vamos pra
isso né
eu fiquei pensando em aceitar quando a
gente vai trabalhar transformação
a gente vai trabalhar a ação a gente
precisa sair de um ponto certo
hoje eu quero compartilhar com vocês uma
ferramenta uma ferramenta de pesquisa
etnográfica que saiu de um ponto um
ponto de incômodo
nessa foto você está vendo grande
malinovski entre os nativos das ilhas
trowbridge e dá para você perceber que
apesar de ele está fazendo ali aquilo
que o tornou famoso a observação
participante é ele participa mas ele
continua sendo marinov que ele continua
sendo um outsider até um certo ponto
então isso incomodou as pessoas lá na
década de 70 se como é que a gente pode
coletar dados como a gente pode
transformar é o nosso engajamento ea
nossa pesquisa em ação em ação deles por
eles e aí surgiu essa sacada e ter a
caneta não seja você o cara escrevendo
sobre eles
por mais que você esteja vivendo dentro
vivendo com não seja você o cara
escrevendo por eles entrega caneta e
deixa que eles escrevam por eles mesmos
deixa que eles façam e que sintam
pertença né a grande frase a grande
chave é pertença
então o que eu quero falar hoje para
vocês é só uma ferramenta que é como um
kit é um kit de ação chama pl a
participatory warning anexo pode chamar
de zé a gente pode chamar de carlos hoje
pode chamar empresário participativo
volume pouco importa quando ele chega
com o nome em inglês as pessoas já não
temos é um software não não é um
software é um kit com esse kit funciona
assim a gente tem um momento de corte
transversal momento em que a gente vai
caminhar pelo espaço que a gente quer
transformar e vai identificar o que a
gente sente que a gente pode botar
outras camadas desse corte transversal e
pode botar a camada da grana
a gente pode botar camada da mobilidade
voltar quantas camadas a gente quiser
normalmente a primeira camada que eu
coloco a camada do sentir o que a gente
sente quando a gente caminha de um ponto
a ao ponto b
e aí nesse caminhar a gente vai tomando
nota ok
senti isso sentir aquilo neste momento
aqui me senti um cômodo enorme
então a gente se caminhar do ponto a ao
ponto b é o corte transversal então esse
é o primeiro ponto do kit
o segundo ponto do kit é identificar
problemas grandes e tentar lapidar
chegar em problemas pequenos ea gente
usa uma técnica chamada árvore problema
é que as pessoas se desesperam
normalmente porque surgem mais problemas
que você ainda não tinha visto mas que
estão ali se faça putz cara tem muito
mais do que imaginava
então a árvore problema é o nosso
segundo passo é primeiro passo é a gente
caminhar identificar os incômodos o
segundo passo é dentro desses incômodos
quais são os reais problemas daí a rede
parte pra ideação gerar soluções para
aqueles probleminhas específicos que a
gente identificou na caminhada e que a
gente identificou lá na árvore problema
é que eu uso essa técnica chama 356 é
uma técnica em locais e dor
são três ideias por pessoa porque estão
seis pessoas três delas em cinco minutos
seis pessoas
a gente tem um grupo de seis no máximo
seis cada uma dessas pessoas precisa
gerar 5 e 3 10
então é uma explosão de idéias uma
explosão de soluções que depois vão ser
mergulhados para levar a ação
e aí a gente tem que priorizar tá nesse
mundão de ações e de idéias e percepções
e de incômodos
o que é que a gente vai levar a ação a
gente fala de identificar um problema é
um primeiro passo
solucionar o problema é um segundo passo
gigantesco priorizar é a chave
jogar todas a sua vontade todo seu todo
seu desejo toda sua intenção em algo que
precisa ser transformado então a gente
prioriza e depois a gente parte para a
ação então lembra daquela escola que eu
falei lá no começo
alcina a gente vai fazer isso lá um
projeto chamado komova komova mover
junto a este carro perguntando e aí que
você sai da prefeitura você é da
secretaria que vai da gente eu falei
'não nós vamos fazer isso juntos se
vocês quiserem se vocês quiserem
e a gente foi lá próximo a gente reúne
um grupo de voluntários que a gente
propôs a eles
voluntariado também região ter que vir
para a escola em dias em horários que
eles não estão na escola ea gente passou
a identificar então a gente usou o corte
transversal para identificar os
incômodos andando pela escola nesse
caminhar a gente identificou alguns
incômodos e aí desses incômodos a gente
melhorou o usuário problema para
identificar os reais problemas
escondidos naquele naqueles incômodo
vizinhos que surgiram no caminhar
identificando esses reais problemas
a gente partiu para priorizar e para
gerar soluções certo então um processo
de desenho coletivo de soluções a pele a
é isso uma ferramenta é uma tecnologia
social do desenho coletivo de soluções e
daí a gente começou a executar a gente
adotou um espaço da escola estava
abandonado e cercado de grades dá pra
ver algumas delas atrás das grades por
exemplo tem um monte de carteira
abandonada
algumas delas ainda com plástico mais
abandonadas
então a gente adotou um espaço que era
um espaço de incômodo que a gente
identificou naquela que naquele corte
transversal a gente encontrou problemas
específicos dentro desse incômodo ea
gente partiu o coração executor e depois
a gente celebrou este espaço foi adotado
não foi pelo gustavo não foi por uma
empresa foi pela escola e envolveu os
coordenadores e se envolver os
professores com o trabalho que levou no
total quais seis meses envolveu muito as
crianças da escola envolveu muito
trabalhar aquilo que é ser humano a
conjugalidade
a pertença então queria deixar vocês com
uma frase linda que eu já que eu adoro
ataque as coisas e aí eu não sou um
grande fã de card mas ele me ajudou aqui
a frase de kart
e eu penso que na verdade pertence vamos
porque existimos pertenço logo existo
a gente precisa pertencer a gente
precisa de tecnologias sociais de
pertencimento de ação de engajamento
então queria fazer um convite vamos
pertence junto vamos voltar a existir
obrigada